let's finish the [ __ ] job before this
breaks chef let's get you out here no I
am NOT flying out to our Jesse's to be
the face of this know what the [ __ ] are
you doing on the phone Siobhan this
episode are chesties which is like a
media and money conference and there's
just deals deals deals deals everywhere
might have just touched Bill Gates and
all these massive mega deals happen in
these kind of weird ski lodges so we
always felt it'd be a interesting place
to say an episode maybe we shouldn't go
with atm we're listening okay seeing Tom
and Gregg down by the waterfall and
outside the movie theater as they
discussed this unfortunate information
they find out about what the company AP
GE has been doing there's a gray area in
terms of our data collection so that we
are kind of like we actually are
listening you know I come from a comedy
writing background and there's something
very comfortable for me about seeing two
very able comic performers do a bit
we're listening yeah well it's just to
like maximize the user experience but if
that was to break the Roy's are here
permission to never [ __ ] bored when a
scandal hits you quickly take on a
different set of values and a different
perspective which is able to distance
yourself from the misdeeds itself its
cultural splashback we're being punished
for the sins of others logan himself in
the teeth of a proxy battles everyone
has that straw that breaks the camel's
back you've tortured the old dinosaur at
a tipping point you barbecued him live
it's not like the most violent attack in
the world this if this think about the
suddenness and the ferocity and the
surprise and the I guess that is
misdirected you might say he was angry
not with Roman but was chef and the fact
that Roman gets it might be an
interesting observation about the way
the anger and frustration rebounds
around inside a family it's a tempest in
a tea kettle relax
I drink oh by the pint it's over
hey hey I haven't finished I think in
that moment you see Logan's fear a
certain point people walk away in that
point I guess it's what's intriguing to
us what is too much because the world is
tough in the world is grubby and you end
up having to bend yourself to people
around you when do you decide that
you're bending too far in your Stein to
corrupt something inside it's an
interesting question
you